l'environnement avec cette nouvelle
pièce à verser au dossier des ogm à des
experts français estiment qu'une variété
de maïs autorisé il y a quelques mois en
france et en europe a des effets
toxiques sur le foie et les reins des
rats utilisés comme cobayes
les auteurs de cette étude financée en
partie par greenpeace et qui est
contesté il faut lire demande d'un
moratoire et de nouveaux tests c'est le
dossier de cette édition il est signé
jérôme soûlard jean-marie lequertier le
maïs monsanto 863 aînés de la recherche
privée américaine dans les années 80 sa
particularité un gène artificiels qui
empêchent les attaques d'insectes sur
les cultures
résultat le petit coléoptère été rasées
et les rendements agricoles bien
meilleure autorisé en france depuis deux
ans il est aujourd'hui jugé dangereux
par certains scientifiques trois
universitaires français ont retravaillé
les résultats de l'étude fournies par
monsanto le fabricant mais il 132 pages
d' analyse le suivi d'une colonie de
rats nourris 90 jours avec ce maïs ogm
d'après the mon 863 serait impropre à la
consommation
nous avons remarqué des effets sur la
santé des rats en tout cas des signes de
toxicité pas tant même si on ne peut pas
dire de quelle maladie il s'agit on
remarque le foie et les reins sont
déréglés ces tests montrent des effets
des signes toxiques
donc franchement qu'ils continueraient à
dire que les ogm sont sains et qu'il
faut en manger prendrait un risque grave
sur la santé publique en 2005 pourtant
d'autres experts ceux du ministère de
l'agriculture avait validé ces mêmes
analyses fournies par le fabricant
monsanto sans état d'âme
marc fellous et ses collègues autorisait
alors la vente du monde 1863 sur le
territoire français nous avons jamais de
certitudes nous disons avec les
connaissances d'aujourd'hui avec les
résultats que nous avons nous pensons
que mais comme nous n'avons jamais 100%
je suis personne à 100% sa team dans la
vie
nous demandons quand même toujours
associé à notre autorisation une
surveillance est ce qu'on appelle la bio
vigilance chez monsanto le semencier
américain on réfute en bloc ces enquêtes
inquiétante aujourd'hui dans le monde
les ogm représente 102 millions
d'hectares cultivés quatre fois la
surface agricole de la france des
millions de consommateurs depuis 15 ans
et selon le fabricant pas un problème de
santé signalés
soyons clairs personne n'a intérêt n'a
envie de mettre un produit qui soit
dangereux pour la santé
et tout sera fait pour éviter ce genre
de choses et en est encore une fois
depuis que les cultures génétiquement
modifiées sont cultivées elles ont été
largement étudiés avant mise sur le
marché et après la mise sur le marché et
aucun incident n'a été relevé aucun
incident notable n'a été relevée et
documenté scientifiquement et
l'indépendance scientifique justement
aujourd'hui les experts qui décident nom
que les analyses des fabricants ogm pour
trancher des travaux classés
confidentiels par les firmes privées
donc inaccessible aux autres chercheurs
en 2005 c'est une décision de justice
qui a permis l'accès aux données sur le
maïs 863 les contradicteurs
commençait alors leurs travaux
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que je
trouve scandaleux que les fabricants de
gm et les gouvernements oppose le secret
industriel de manière à éviter qu'il
puisse y avoir un vrai débat
scientifique sur les effets en termes
sanitaires des ogm quand des études font
apparaître des possibilités de risques
aujourd'hui en france de nombreux
produits génétiquement modifiés sont en
vente libre dans le commerce
faut-il en avoir peur faut-il encore
donner du temps aux spécialistes pour
trancher sur ces questions les
scientifiques continuent de se déchirer